هذه هي اللحظات الأخيرة من حياة هالة ر.
يمكنك رؤيتها هنا تقود
مجموعة مكونة من 30 شخصًا غريبًا يلوحون
بالأعلام البيضاء مناشدين الخروج الآمن من
حيهم المحاصر الآن
بالقوات الإسرائيلية، وهي تمسك بيد طفلها البالغ من
العمر 5 سنوات  حفيد T بإحكام ثم
فجأة تهرب Little T سريعًا بينما
يندفع ابنها محمد نحوها. إذا
أبطأت الفيديو، يمكنك رؤية
هولا تبدأ في الدوران قبل أن يتم
إطلاق النار عليها كما لو أنها رأت
شيئًا ما من زاوية سقوطها
وحركة المجموعة الهاربة من
الواضح أن الرصاصة جاءت من الغرب
أو الجنوب وقد حددت
موقع التقاطع. أخبرنا محمد أنه عندما
وصل إلى والدته نظر إلى الأعلى ورأى
دبابتين إسرائيليتين أمامه إلى
الجنوب وعلى بعد مسافة قصيرة.  على بعد 200 متر إلى الغرب،
نعلم أن القوات الإسرائيلية كانت متمركزة في
مدرسة غزة الإعدادية الجديدة للبنين كما تم
التقاطها هنا في صور الأقمار الصناعية
وصورة نشرت في 12 تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) في
اليوم الذي قُتلت فيه هولا، انظر إلى سارة
ابنة هال البالغة من العمر 18 عامًا وقد عادت إلى
الخلف  في المجموعة الآن بأمان في
إسطنبول، أخبرتنا أن العائلة كانت
تتألم بشأن مغادرة
منزلهم، ولكن بعد ليلتين من
القصف الأكثر كثافة حتى الآن، قررت الانتقال
لتأخذ
وقتك،
فهي تريد أن نتذكر هالة لأنها
كانت في الحياة مخلصة  الجدة التي
لا تزال تعد شطائر سارة لتأخذها إلى
الجامعة لتناول طعام الغداء،
معلمة الأدب العربي المتقاعدة والمحبوبة من قبل
طلابها
وعائلتها، كان الشهر السابق ليوم 7 أكتوبر هو
أسعد الأوقات بالنسبة
للعائلة التي تحتفل بخطوبة سارة
وتخرج محمد من
الجامعة، إنه سؤال يطرحه الكثيرون
يتساءلون مع ظهور المزيد من مقاطع الفيديو
لمدنيين غير مسلحين يرفعون الأعلام البيضاء
بالرصاص على ما يبدو،
يقول مراقب حقوق الإنسان الأورومتوسطي ومقره جنيف لشبكة CNN
إنهم يحققون في تسع
حوادث من هذا القبيل قمنا بتحليل أربعة منها، والأكثر
انتشارًا هو إطلاق النار على
الرهائن الإسرائيليين الثلاثة الذين اعترف بهم الجيش الإسرائيلي
القتل تحت
الانطباع الخاطئ بأن استسلامهم كان
فخًا، أحدث حادث وقع
هذا الأسبوع في معاسي بجنوب
غزة، يقول رمزي أبو سهول البالغ من العمر 51 عامًا
إنه يحاول العودة إلى المنزل
الذي تحتجز فيه
إسرائيل شقيقه  القوات للمطالبة بإطلاق سراحه،
الكاميرا تكبر دبابتين إسرائيليتين
خلف الساتر يمكن سماع طائرة بدون طيار تحلق
فوق رمزي وأربعة أفراد آخرين من العائلة
يتحركون مؤقتًا إلى الأمام
في الهواء، العلم الأبيض مرفوع عاليًا ثم
فجأة يسقط رمزي من إطلاق النار
على
على الأرض، إذا أبطأت سرعة الفيديو،
يمكنك رؤية تأثير الطلقة الأولى
على
الحائط التي تم إطلاقها بوضوح من اتجاه
الدبابات، حيث قام الرجال بسحب جثة رمزي على عجل بعيدًا،
والعلم الأبيض الآن ملطخ
بالدماء، وتركض زوجته وراءه لكنه
مات بالفعل  مقطع
فيديو آخر حصلت عليه سي إن إن
سجله الصحفي رامي أبو جاموس في
10 تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر)، يقول إن الجيش الإسرائيلي أمر
عائلته بإخلاء منزلهم
وحمل أعلام بيضاء
[تصفيق]
أثناء سيرهم ويمكن سماع طلقات نارية
على الجانب الآخر من الشارع.
يندب على جثة ابنه القتيل
عهد
[موسيقى]
عند الزاوية شخصان آخران
أصيبا بالرصاص ويحملان
أعلامًا بيضاء. لا تستطيع سي إن إن تحديد من أطلق الطلقات، لقد
أرسلنا إحداثيات جميع
الأحداث إلى جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي وطلبنا مرارًا
التعليق، لقد طارنا  لقد طلبنا من إسرائيل الجلوس
مع جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي وعرضنا عليهم الاطلاع على
نتائج
تحقيقنا معهم أمام الكاميرا أو خارجها،
وفي النهاية رفضوا مقابلتنا ولم
يقدموا بعد
بيانًا، فقد دُفنت هالة في
قبر ضحل في مقبرة صغيرة.  الزقاق المجاور لمنزل
العائلة شاهد قبرها مكتوب
بالطباشير وتأمل عائلتها أن تتحقق
العدالة لمقتلها وأن يتم
دفنها بشكل مناسب عندما تنتهي هذه الحرب أخيرًا